[Music]
alright guys so today I'm gonna be doing
a review on coffee crisis to me coffee
crisis is a pretty interesting game I
really enjoyed how it was like a hack
and slash and to me it's like one of
those arcade games and I haven't really
played too many of those like kind of
hack and slash arcade games and I
thought it was a really interesting game
I like the concept how they added coffee
cuz there's not really too many video
games where they have like coffee in it
and it's like one of those beat em up
games and I thought it was pretty
interesting how like I had old people
and stuff like that did I don't know how
somebody would come up with that but it
was pretty cool concept to me coffee
crisis was kind of a really hard game
like to me I don't really like those
games where if you die and you're like
halfway through the game it takes you
all the way back in the beginning like I
know some people like that but for me I
just really not really too much into
that those type of games and then
there's like aliens in it and stuff like
that
which I thought was pretty interesting
and then you like teleport to the next
area and then there's like each button
is a different move so it's kind of like
one of those fighting games like Street
Fighter how they have certain combos
it's kind of like that and to be honest
I think that a coffee crisis would be
one of those games where if it's on sale
for a cheap click cheap price that's
when you'd go and definitely want to
pick it up like you know I'd say if
you're really into hack and slash games
pick this name up immediately like I
know people some people may not like it
but I mean if you're looking for a game
that's a reasonable price pick this one
up and if you're looking for something
different like these hack and slash
games are pretty fun plus I mean
especially if you're on the go
as there aren't too many of those arcade
games on the go there like hacking
slashes didn't let's forget like
emulators like Soulja Boy your any now
and then um yeah if this game is on sale
I'd say pick it up you know if it's like
three or four bucks it's definitely
worth of buy because I mean no you can't
beat a price for that and it the only
thing I didn't really like about is how
you beat up hold people it's kind of
rude but I mean hey it's a cool concept
I guess um pick up the coffee bits and
use those to activate your power which I
thought that was pretty cool and some of
the enemies are really hard like to take
out the alien part up is like pretty
cool and then you can like interact with
stuff in the background like you can hit
over trash cans and stuff like that
which I really enjoy it as in most games
don't really go out of their way to do
stuff like that
but this one is one of those games that
does and you can pick up like bats off
the ground and start whacking aliens
with it and stuff and then they also
have a mode where like activates the
screen and to like an old TV style like
the ones where it's like all black and
white and it's like has like the line
going up and down the stream or up and
down the screen just thought that was
pretty interesting and then like yeah
and it's really enjoyable I think and
then I really like to thank the iron
Lords podcaster group and Cognito for
helping me and given me this opportunity
to start doing this I am MJ is a boss I
stream on iron Lords podcast twitch
channel every Monday once a week just
about it depends I'm probably going to
start trying to do it more over the
summer shot it's it's a really fun
opportunity
really thankful to have it but if you
guys like really into hacking slash
games and arcade games I definitely say
you want to check out coffee crisis so
yeah guys thank you guys for watching
[Music]